welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to rim of the world has just
dropped on Netflix and the fun-filled
movie has a lot to impart from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the film
as well as what I took from it this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the movie yet and don't want to
have anything roon for yourself then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video I hope you enjoy it now sit back
relax and let's get to my breakdown of
rim of the world rim of the world
follows a group of four misfit teenagers
who find themselves in the midst of an
alien invasion during summer camp the
group have no adults or guides to help
show them the way so they have to face
their peers band together and become a
team in order to save the world
what I love about this film is from the
author it's clear homage is to
Independence Day with the ships flying
into orbit gravity with the continuous
shot in space and there are many musical
cues that lead back to et and more this
really feels like a brilliant sci-fi
movie that clearly wears its influences
like the purge gladiator Jurassic Park
alien the thing and even Schindler's
List on its sleeve even seeing the
actress that played agent Reyes and the
x-files is similar to seeing Michael J
Fox pop up in sea yesterday and it still
does a fantastic job of getting sci-fi
fans like myself hooked from the intro
as the teams arrive at camp rim of the
world I was actually surprised at how
risky and innuendo laced the humor was
there's a couple of laugh-out-loud
moments and the camp guide is absolutely
hilarious actually think adults will
enjoy this more than kids and as we head
into the invasion this definitely
becomes more stranger things than
Goonies this is a grand level view of an
invasion and we see air dogfights from
the kids perspectives as well as what it
would be like to be in this scenario
they are entrusted with a special key
that when used that NASA's Jet
Propulsion lab will be able to
apparently vanquish the threat on the
way they get chased down by several
aliens and one of the characters ends up
giving well potentially
aliens junk in their mouths along the
way their friendship grows stronger and
with scenes like Alex learning to ride a
bike because his father could never
teach him after his death this
coming-of-age story has a pretty big
heart to it all of them bond and I
respect how much of a real-life take the
film took on the teenagers this is
really relatable in bar an alien
invasion a lot of things similar
happened to me growing up so I
definitely appreciate how real-world the
dialogue felt eventually they reach the
facility to find dr. fielding dead
however after transmission comes on
attempting to pull them out of the area
they stand up for themselves and find
out about Excalibur a way to destroy the
mothership in high orbit each member of
the group really gets their moment in
the spotlight and the action-packed
ending reveals that Alex was actually
the cause of his father's death after he
refused to move during a house fire that
meant his father had to run in after him
he sees visions of his dad who's clearly
been watching over him in the film with
things like the car that appeared
earlier and Alex confronts his fear and
the guilty faces are causing his
father's death and he escapes the
crumbling facility with the ship
destroyed the invasion is over and the
world is safe we get an awesome credit
scene of the group being knighted by the
Queen which by the way is happening on
the day that Theresa May steps down as
Prime Minister wish I found quite funny
they do a car karaoke with another
British person that everyone in Britain
hates and the group go on to be
world-famous musicians which is
absolutely hilarious it ends it on an
amazing no and I sort of got flashbacks
to Bill and Ted and then that sort of
aesthetic which I really appreciate it
and now on to my review well as you can
get I'm very very pleased with the film
Netflix have been smashing it recently
with both this and see yesterday being
two of the most enjoyable films this
year this is a blast from start to
finish
and I know that if it was a teen I would
have absolutely lapped it up it
perfectly balances the humor drama and
every character feels fully developed
and acts like an actual teenager would
this is a brilliant movie from beginning
to end and I definitely think it's the
one to watch this weekend if you don't
want to see Aladdin and are too young
for bright burn overall I had a lot of
fun with the film and it gets an 8.5 out
of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the movie and what you took from it
make sure you leave your review and
favorite jokes in the comments below
mine's probably it's another 7-eleven
and it's Independence Day what do you
mean it's tuna I butchered that but it
was really funny when I watched it
anyway if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of this week's
other big movie Brite burn which would
be linked at the end we've also just
launched a merchandise section on the
channel so if you want to support videos
like this and get something back from it
then make sure you click the links in
the boxes below this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]